desculpa já estava nascendo wifi no qual
é a senha do iphan
eu jurei não agora pôde assim vai ficar
muito mais fácil chegar por kassab o
suspeito fala agora quem vai pagar essa
luta tem no meu site o primeiro na
descrição do vídeo é nóis o estado 14
argentino quase não usa na vida no dia
que você ainda quer passado em mais
rápidos e mais um parceiro
e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
com você e eu tô a delícia quando vocês
podem perceber o meu peito mas eu fui ao
cinema assistir mais uma vez o santos
batman e superman é tipo um namoro tempo
no namoro está tudo bem ea namorada do
cabo inventa que tenho uma coisa pra
brigar porque os dois são super heróis e
o que é salvar a cidade maior que o tipo
das crianças brigando nas coisas que já
fizeram meu filho porque eu já só viu a
terra de um asteróide ou você vocês
sabem também que aqui teve um monte de
gangsters que eu matei ele com todas as
minhas coisas e batman mas eu sei voa
anémica roupa mas nega né não só falta
aparecer um homem de ferro vai deixar de
assistir em 3d é sócia filme 3d corre
muito mas aprendeu assistindo namorada
mensagem chegou a mensagem 3d o filme em
3d nossa gente a magia do cinema pela
comcast o filme 3d mas melhor que
assistir o filme 3d é pegar dois jogos
3d e assistir em seis desde o filme
começa com do sul em quando era criança
e ele cai no buraco
a é a demora a cair
quem mora em morar
a demorando muito leva chibatadas no
chão gata explicado menino desse tamanho
caiu por não sei quantas horas meta a
cabeça no chão é bosch batalha e não
morre em que seu batismo - só que era só
um sonho era só um sonho que o pobre é
mesmo o pai morreu na frente dele e aí
ele fica três sessões a vida inteira e o
filme de ação começa com invasão
alienígena
muitos figurantes correndo pra lá e pra
cá os figurões correr pela fez da câmera
acham que vai aparecer o filho na
participei do filme uma vez com o filme
batman e superman ficará com a parte que
aparece cada pé nessa parte que causa a
ele borrada cara com mendonça participou
do filme é o cara participou do filme é
lá que a lei islâmica é namorada do
superman a entrevistar um terrorista um
terrorista sequestro a lois lane que é
namorada do super nem o cara seco é a
namorada do super mês kb do eubra de
chegar perto da namorada do léo estronda
ver o lado do super mesmo esse super man
vem com sangue no olho
sentiu a pressão do efeito especial
cabível em condições eu não tenho como a
galera não conhece o superman é que pode
acabar com um óculos e outra pessoa eu
não posso dar sim eu boto pra na rua
recife no povo começa a ficar meio com
ódio do superman que eu pegue um carro
muito forte o cara ele não consegue
salvar as pessoas sem destruir assim os
23 prédio não consegue dar um rumo e não
consegue dar ao mundo uma pessoa sem
quebrar 1 a 10 15 para ele agora é que
começam a busca assim o superman negra
começa pichar a estátua do super mental
para até 40 quarenta anos de prisão por
que pichou a estátua do superman isso
que ele pichou estado do supermercado 30
anos de prisão mas se tivesse estuprado
uma pessoa eu condeno sujeito a 286 anos
de prisão cada um com 110 já para morrer
e a polícia você não vai morrer não você
não vai morrer agora você vai ter mais
200 anos de prisão que cumpriu seu fela
bakus eko grosso oemt abaixo a toda hora
de dormir e sonhar com alguma coisa
algum pesado eu sou educado é massa e do
sonho do cabo tem tiro
a explosão superman e foi especial pé
depois de uma manhã que é tão rico até o
sonho dele mas ela tem uma cena do filme
huacho mas tal perseguição aquele calção
preto do batman que carro do batman tem
os carros na vida que você a esse carro
mas sky folga sky [ __ ] e tem um carro do
batman porque não é que o carro massa
que o carro é do batman podia ser um
palio é o batman dirigindo o carro do
meu palio do batman a mulher pode
recusar em lisboa está a indicar
bernanke carvalho dizer que cai do
batman que essa perseguição ea música
trilha sonora do filme ajuda trilha
sonora de filme ajuda em tudo olha essa
cena que com trilha sonora
agora olha essa cena sem trilha sonora
não vou falar se do patamar não diretor
não roubar não dá emoção c3 hora na não
fique escroto e o carro do batman é [ __ ]
eles pode tudo tem um carro na frente de
doni spode o carro de outro carro foto
carro
ele é bom ver que se fosse eu baixar o
vídeo eu sou batma a hora que o cara sai
da fertilidade feito com o prédio o
carro está de frente para um prédio o
carro do batman atravessa o canal do
bairro através de um prédio para talvez
um isopor com esse carro fala ai tu nada
parece super no câmera lenta bonitão
peitão bundão rola grande naquela casa
balançando em câmera lenta o carro [ __ ]
do bairro perto do superman ver o fit um
2009 que eu sou superman é o caso do
barco
eu passei eu sei que depois dá esse
bairro com sangue nos zóio começa o
treino pra pegar o superman levanta peso
ocorre coxa corda empurra carro levanta
pneu mas traz crítico lucas nunca ficar
fora chega o momento do tiro é o da
alopatia aparece com armadura de ferro
nem o céu é começa logo chegou à frente
a frente os dois seita carai também
copiar 14 anos é mesmo isso permitiu ao
méxico caçamba jogando a bomba é rubin
que eu perdi claire sos a nesse bate e
rebate ainda joga bomba de kriptonita
superman fica fraco esse bate mas
educacenso permitem uma perna joga na
parede lá meu deus do céu nunca viu seu
caminho apoiado o que está acontecendo
shui senhor se fosse um super meu apelo
psicológico porque está me batendo dizer
sim pode bater você pode me bater agora
do vitor saber voar pode recomeçar
só pelo menor de você não é um é muita
pancada eu sei que depois disso tudo
eles viram amigos e começam a lutar
juntos por outra causa porque eu não vou
ficar contando aqui você assistir o
filme você vai saber porque eu acho
massa do batman é porque tiveram muito
engenhoso e joga um negócio pra cá moram
aqui ele joga o filho pra cima no
telhado era um cabo e puxa ele torna o
negócio do barueri joga pra frente cada
morte atrás droga falar mata pra cá o
carro é todo o contrário o fmi já pelo
grupo h pela rua só por enquanto isso
enquanto batmans educação e os caba do
mal superman vai à tarde o ex piloto
enquanto o filho estava acontecendo é
que o ex botafoguense estava criando o
satanás sério - a tam acaba criando um
monstro que é o fator negativo assim a o
batman não matou super - o primeiro
matou barco povo criar o satanás agora
ele vai ver o cão literalmente de
sacanagem
há um bicho gigante tipo tamanho de um
prédio tipo hulk só tomando lei própria
mas a pancadaria e superman batendo o
satanás satanás batendo super bem super
meia volta e ficava com o espaço que é e
pipo espaço eu fosse assim eu não sei
pois passa não fui catira missio num
satanás só que o suplementar junto com o
satã acaba provei que o superman levou o
satanás pois parte mec no início nos
peitos suplementar junto cara que o
satanás do filme morre não cá ele cai na
terra volta e fica é mais forte quanto
mais bate mais forte ele fique e ele
volta ao papel que até o batman o que
diabo é que o pobre do batman vai fazer
com o satanás o sábado fica frente a
frente com batman ele vai voltar àquele
raio laser pelos oito matar o batman que
se desmata karachi a mulher maravilha
aparece segurando aqui no curso unidade
corre o cara vai tomar no meu cuca
eu vou me masturbar no cinema eu vou o
superman volta ao vivo do espaço ímpar
esse filme é muito bom ter gostado do
meu deus esse filme está muito bom ter o
acaso mas quando eu vi a mulher
maravilha eu vi um supermercado eu vi o
que estava acontecendo eu vi o perigo eu
vi a desgraça que estava acontecendo só
percebi uma coisa agora só tem uma saída
foge foge mulher maravilha
olha
o bb concluiu os três junto enfileiro
batman mulher maravilha super meu deus
do céu e subiu à equipe a que se
levantem os cabelos udine é maravilha
papo para um pai é por causa dos peito
não isso pra mim é ter um raio pelo pai
mas também pelo o que eu acho que quando
terminou o filme superman foi fazer um
exame de vista é muita briga muita coisa
muita informação do filme eram membros
seguinte esse filme acaba eu só quero
saber uma coisa qual é o gel que o
superman uso que [ __ ] que pariu faz meia
hora no meu cabelo abordou de dia se o
vidro do carro super mesmo a 300 por
hora é uma prévia através do aparelho é
um show de rock entra na roda punk o
cabelo do cabo no méxico um filme mas é
isso aí eu adorei o filme se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo aqui que eu falei
sobre o filme clique aqui no youtube em
gostei que vai me ajudar em mais fotos
no facebook eu postei esse vídeo aqui e
curtir você vai deixar muito feliz e
marca dos comentários meus amigos que já
assistiram batman e superman o vão
assistir ainda não confirma que eu só
cotações que eu achei engraçado mas você
não assistiu faixa no cara e fui
obrigado a assistir esse vídeo até aqui
em nós se inscreve no canal nunca peguei
um vídeo novo